The House Ways and Means Committee
now has access to six years
of Donald Trump's tax returns.
What are they going to do with them?
Yeah,
so they have to decide now
that they have access, how exactly
they're going to handle the returns.
That could actually be a main point
in a meeting
they're going to have
with legal counsel tomorrow.
The big thing, though, is
it's still unclear
if the public
will actually get to see these
six years of Trump's tax returns.
We know that the public and all of us
definitely won't get immediate access
to them.
It's possible
they could be released
sometime down the road.
Of course,
that could impact
Trump's presidential bid
that he's announced for 20, 24.
Trump has already for years
repeatedly
refused to release his tax returns
throughout 2016 2020 campaigns,
even throughout his presidency.
We did get a glimpse of information
from the New York Times back in 2020
they found that Trump
paid no federal income taxes at all
beginning in 2000.
So we could see potentially in the future
depending on what
the House Ways
and Means Committee decides
to do with these returns.
What else might be buried
in six years of Trump's tax returns.
But it's not anything
the public is going to see any soon.
And this committee has just weeks
before they wrap up
to really decide
how they want to handle them as well
John. All right.
Jessica Snyder, thank you so much.
With us
now is investigative
reporter and Trump biographer David Cay.
Johnson, author of The Big Cheat
How Donald Trump Fleeced America
and Enriched Himself and His Family.
So, David,
the House Ways and Means Committee,
they don't have much time
to investigate
the former president's taxes
if they want.
Do Democrats only control this committee
for another month or so?
So what are the most immediate questions
that could be answered
by these documents?
Well, they could tell us definitively
whether Donald,
on his tax returns, manipulated
the value of assets
he was depreciating
when you own an asset like a building,
you get to write off
part of the cost of it each year
and it saves your tax dollars.
And we know from The New York
Times investigation four years ago
that Trump manipulated values
all over the place to deal with loans
and insurance documents.
So that would be one of the first things
to look for.
And second,
to look for numbers that don't match up.
You claim to have X amount of money
in the bank in a particular account
at the end of an entity.
Donald has 500 entities,
and the amount of money
you have the next year doesn't match up.
It should be exactly to close out
the start of the next year.
But they
don't have much time
to look at that,
if that's what they want to do.
So the tax returns and questions
are primarily
from the period
when Donald Trump was president,
when he was in the White House.
So how do you think
that affects the investigation?
Well, I'd be much more interested
John, in seeing the tax returns
before he became president,
because there's testimony in the ongoing
New York City
trial on tax
cheating by the Trump organization
that they cleaned up their behavior
once Donald Trump
arrived in the White House.
But the issue
the committee was concerned
about was Donald
Trump's repeated claims
that he was persecuted by the IRS
because he's a Christian.
Never mind
that he has called in a book
Christians Fools and Schmucks and Idiots
and has declared
repeatedly his life's
philosophy is revenge,
which is inherently anti Christian.
That was
the issue was the president
of the United States
and a presidential candidate
being treated properly by the IRS?
That's an issue
I can imagine the Democrats might
the Republicans might want to get into,
depending on how facts
turn out in the future.
Not likely, but possible
since they're always trying
to beat up the IRS.
So the chair of the House Ways and Means
Committee, Richie Neal,
declined to say
whether they would release
any of these returns publicly.
Do you think any of these will
see the light of day
Well, I hope so.
First and foremost,
Ricky Neil is very concerned
about a section of the tax code
that makes tax returns confidential.
They used to be public record
100 years ago, they were public,
but they're not.
Now, there are procedures
by which the committee
can put the tax returns
into the public record.
He's having a meeting with his caucus
on the committee.
And I think one of the things
they're certain to discuss is,
is there a way for them
to put this into the congressional record
so that it's always there
and people on the outside
can basically crowdsource an audit?
Look, the former president's
legal team has fought for years,
so as a former president
to keep this secret.
You've reported on him extensive valley.
Why do you think he worked so hard
to keep these from going public?
Because Donald's a tax cheat.
I mean,
I've established in the public record
previously he cheated on sales taxes.
He cheated on payroll taxes,
actually even cheated
not a roulette players
at one of his casinos.
And The New York Times
investigation
that they said was inspired
by my reporting
four years ago
showed very, very calculated
income tax cheating by the Trump family.
It also involved
gift tax and estate tax cheating.
That's who Trump is.
He's done this his whole life.
He's cheated on investors and workers.
And as I said, even some gamblers So,
of course, the tax returns,
if fully audited, are going to show
that he cheated on his income taxes.
David Cay Johnston,
thank you for your insight.
Thank you, John.